bentornato a Capire l'informazione e il calcolo quantistico, mi chiamo John Watrous e sono il direttore tecnico per l'educazione presso IBM
Quantum. Questa è la lezione numero 15 della serie ed è la terza lezione della quarta unità, dedicata alla correzione degli errori quantistici.
Finora abbiamo visto alcuni esempi di codici correttori di errori quantistici, tra cui il codice di Shore a nove qubit,
il codice di Steane a 7 qubit e il codice a 5 qubit, e abbiamo anche discusso il formalismo degli stabilizzatori, che fornisce
una base matematica dalla quale possiamo descrivere e analizzare questi e molti altri codici correttori di errori quantistici.
I codici che ho appena menzionato sono indubbiamente interessanti e rappresentano un punto di partenza naturale per
l'esplorazione della correzione degli errori quantistici. Il problema è che possono tollerare solo un tasso di errore molto basso.
Correggere un errore su un qubit su cinque, sette o nove non è male, ma con ogni probabilità, almeno per quanto sospettiamo,
avremo bisogno di tollerare molti più errori di così per rendere il calcolo quantistico su larga scala una
realtà. In questa lezione daremo un primo sguardo ad alcune costruzioni di codici correttori di errori quantistici più sofisticate, inclusi codici che possono
tollerare un tasso di errore molto più elevato rispetto a quelli visti finora e sono considerati candidati promettenti per la correzione pratica degli errori quantistici in
dispositivi fisici reali. Ecco una breve panoramica della lezione. Inizieremo con una classe di
codici correttori di errori quantistici noti come codici CSS, chiamati così in onore dei ricercatori che li hanno scoperti per primi: Robert Calderbank, Peter
Shor e Andrew Steane. La costruzione dei codici CSS permette di prendere certe coppie di codici
correttori di errori classici e combinarli in un codice correttore di errori quantistici. Come parte di questa discussione,
daremo un'occhiata abbastanza rapida ai codici lineari classici e parleremo anche di alcune proprietà di base dei codici CSS.
La seconda parte della lezione riguarda un codice noto come il codice Toro, che è un esempio fondamentale e davvero
bellissimo di un codice correttore di errori quantistici in grado di tollerare un tasso di errore relativamente alto. In effetti,
il codice Toro non è un singolo esempio di codice correttore di errori quantistici, ma piuttosto è una famiglia infinita di codici, uno per
ogni numero intero positivo a partire da due. Nell'ultima parte della lezione discuteremo brevemente un paio di altre
famiglie di codici quantistici, inclusi i codici surface, strettamente connessi al codice Toro, nonché
i codici colore. Le persone studiano i codici correttori di errori classici dagli anni '40
ed è un argomento affascinante e ricco. I codici lineari sono forse il tipo più semplice di codice correttore di errori classico
e spiegherò esattamente cosa significa la parola "lineare" in questo contesto tra poco. Ma un modo semplice
per esprimere cosa sono è che si tratta di codici stabilizzatori che sono classici, e vedremo presto che
i codici CSS sono fondamentalmente coppie di codici lineari classici combinati insieme per creare un codice correttore di errori
quantistici. Quindi, per questa discussione, dovremo capire alcune cose fondamentali sui
codici lineari classici. Prima di tutto, useremo Σ come alfabeto binario per tutta questa
discussione. Quando ci riferiamo a un codice lineare classico, intendiamo un insieme C di stringhe binarie di lunghezza n per qualche
numero intero positivo n che soddisfa una sola proprietà fondamentale: se u e v sono stringhe binarie in C, allora la stringa
u XOR v è anch'essa in C. Qui, u XOR v indica lo XOR bit a bit di u e v, proprio come
abbiamo visto più volte nelle lezioni cinque e sei nella parte sugli algoritmi quantistici della serie. E questo è ciò che significa per un
codice classico essere lineare: in sostanza stiamo pensando alle stringhe binarie di lunghezza n come vettori n-dimensionali
le cui componenti sono tutte zero o uno, ma invece della normale addizione vettoriale sui numeri reali o complessi,
stiamo usando l'addizione modulo 2, che è semplicemente lo XOR. Quindi se abbiamo
due parole di codice u e v, cioè u e v sono stringhe binarie in C, allora u più v modulo 2, ovvero u XOR
v, deve anch'essa essere una parola di codice in C. Tra l'altro, questa implicazione deve valere anche se u è uguale a v: niente esclude
questa possibilità. E questo implica che ogni codice lineare classico deve contenere la stringa tutta-zero, perché lo
XOR bit a bit di una qualsiasi stringa con se stessa è la stringa tutta-zero. Ad esempio, il
codice di ripetizione a tre bit è un codice lineare classico. In particolare, ci sono due possibili scelte per u e due possibili
scelte per v, ed è abbastanza banale esaminare le possibili coppie per vedere che otteniamo sempre una parola di codice quando prendiamo lo XOR bit a bit.
Ecco un altro esempio, chiamato codice di Hamming [7,4,3]. Questo è uno dei primissimi codici correttori di errori classici
mai scoperto e consiste di 16 stringhe binarie di lunghezza sette. C'è una logica molto semplice
alla base della selezione di queste stringhe, ma non la spiegherò in questo video. Devo anche menzionare che a volte vedrai queste stringhe invertite, ma
per ora il punto principale è che se prendiamo due qualsiasi di queste stringhe e facciamo lo XOR, otterremo un'altra stringa nel
codice. È quindi un codice lineare. La notazione [7,4,3] tra parentesi quadre singole significa qualcosa di analogo alla notazione a doppie
parentesi quadre che ho menzionato nella lezione precedente per i codici stabilizzatori, ma qui si tratta di codici lineari
classici. In particolare, le parole di codice hanno sette bit, ci sono 16 parole di codice, quindi possiamo codificare quattro bit usando il codice, e
risulta essere un codice a distanza tre, il che significa che devi invertire almeno tre bit di qualsiasi parola di codice per ottenere una
parola di codice diversa, il che implica che può correggere fino a un errore di flip di bit. Questi sono esempi semplici di
codici, ma anche l'esempio del codice di Hamming [7,4,3] sembra un po' misterioso quando elenchiamo semplicemente tutte le parole di codice, quindi abbiamo bisogno di modi migliori per
descrivere i codici lineari classici. Ci sono due modi naturali per farlo. Un modo è descrivere i codici lineari
classici fornendo un insieme minimale di parole di codice che generano il codice, nel senso che prendendo tutti i possibili
sottoinsiemi di queste parole di codice e facendo lo XOR tra loro otteniamo l'intero codice. Ciò è espresso in termini matematici
sullo schermo. Un altro modo di pensare a questo è che stiamo visualizzando questo codice come un sottospazio di uno spazio vettoriale, e questo insieme
di generatori è una base per quel sottospazio, tenendo presente che si tratta di uno spazio vettoriale in cui l'aritmetica viene eseguita modulo 2. Se abbiamo m generatori,
otterremo un codice con 2 elevato a m elementi: ogni generatore raddoppia il numero di elementi nel codice, e
ciò è coerente con il fatto che i codici lineari classici sull'alfabeto binario includono sempre un numero di stringhe che è una potenza di
due. Il secondo modo naturale per descrivere un codice lineare classico è tramite i controlli di parità: nello specifico, si tratta di un elenco minimale
di stringhe binarie della stessa lunghezza delle stringhe nel codice, tali che le stringhe nel codice sono precisamente quelle il cui prodotto scalare binario
con ognuna di queste stringhe di controllo di parità è zero, dove il prodotto scalare binario è semplicemente il prodotto scalare ordinario
WEBVTT
modulo 2. E di nuovo, è qualcosa che abbiamo incontrato nella lezione cinque nel contesto degli algoritmi di
interrogazione. Il motivo per cui si chiamano stringhe di controllo di parità è che una data stringa u ha prodotto scalare binario uguale a
zero con v se e solo se i bit di u corrispondenti agli uno in v hanno parità
pari. Quando descriviamo un codice lineare classico in questo modo tramite un elenco minimale di stringhe di controllo di parità, ogni stringa di controllo di parità
divide per due il numero di stringhe nel codice, quindi per un singolo codice descritto in questi due modi diversi avremo sempre m + r uguale a
n. Una cosa importante da notare qui è che il prodotto scalare binario non è un prodotto interno in senso formale, e in
particolare quando due stringhe hanno prodotto scalare binario uguale a zero, non significa che sono ortogonali nel senso in cui di solito pensiamo
all'ortogonalità. Ad esempio, il prodotto scalare binario della stringa 1,1 con se stessa è zero, quindi è possibile che
una di queste stringhe di controllo di parità sia essa stessa nel codice. È solo una cosa da tenere a
mente. Ad esempio, come già sappiamo, il codice di ripetizione a 3 bit è un codice lineare, quindi può essere descritto in entrambi questi
modi. In particolare, c'è una sola scelta per un generatore che funziona, ed è 1,1,1, e in alternativa possiamo descrivere
il codice con queste due stringhe di controllo di parità, che dovrebbero sembrare familiari dalle nostre discussioni precedenti su questo
codice. E per il codice di Hamming [7,4,3] possiamo usare questi generatori e questi controlli di parità.
Qui, tra l'altro, tutte le nostre stringhe di controllo di parità risultano essere esse stesse nel
codice. Un commento finale sui codici lineari classici, solo per collegarli al formalismo degli stabilizzatori: queste stringhe di controllo di parità
sono equivalenti ai generatori dello stabilizzatore dove abbiamo solo matrici di Pauli Z e identità. Ad esempio, le stringhe di controllo di parità
1,1,0 e 0,1,1 per il codice di ripetizione a 3 bit corrispondono precisamente ai generatori dello stabilizzatore ZZ identità
e identità ZZ, e ciò è coerente con la nostra discussione degli osservabili di questo tipo nella lezione
precedente. Ora discuteremo dei codici CSS, che sono codici stabilizzatori ottenibili combinando insieme certe
coppie di codici lineari classici con lo stesso numero di bit nelle loro codifiche. Non funziona per qualsiasi coppia di
codici lineari classici: i due codici devono avere una certa relazione, come vedremo presto, ma nonostante ciò
questa costruzione apre molte possibilità per codici correttori di errori quantistici, basandosi in parte su ciò che abbiamo imparato in oltre 75 anni di
teoria della codifica classica. Ho già menzionato che nel formalismo degli stabilizzatori, i generatori dello
stabilizzatore contenenti solo matrici di Pauli Z e identità sono equivalenti ai controlli di parità. Ad esempio, nel codice di ripetizione a tre bit
possiamo usare le stringhe di controllo di parità 1,1,0 e 0,1,1, che impongono che i due bit più a sinistra siano
uguali e i due bit più a destra siano uguali per ogni stringa nel codice. Queste due stringhe di controllo di parità corrispondono precisamente ai generatori dello stabilizzatore
ZZ identità e identità ZZ. Per il codice di Hamming [7,4,3] possiamo usare
queste stringhe di controllo di parità, e corrispondono a questi generatori dello stabilizzatore, dove sostituiamo semplicemente ogni uno con uno Z e ogni zero con l'identità.
Potresti riconoscere questi generatori dello stabilizzatore: sono tre dei sei generatori dello stabilizzatore per il codice di Steane a 7 qubit. Non è
certamente una coincidenza, e vedremo esattamente cosa sta succedendo tra poco. Daremo il nome di generatori Z
dello stabilizzatore ai generatori dello stabilizzatore come questi, nel senso che contengono solo fattori tensoriali di Pauli Z e identità,
quindi X e Y non compaiono mai in un generatore Z dello stabilizzatore. Possiamo anche considerare
generatori dello stabilizzatore dove compaiono solo matrici di Pauli X e identità, e possiamo pensare a generatori dello stabilizzatore come questi come completamente analoghi
ai generatori Z dello stabilizzatore, tranne per il fatto che descrivono essenzialmente controlli di parità nella base più-meno anziché nella
base standard. Ad esempio, tornando al codice di Hamming [7,4,3], possiamo considerare i
rimanenti tre generatori dello stabilizzatore del codice di Steane a 7 qubit, che seguono esattamente lo stesso schema dei generatori Z dello stabilizzatore per questo
codice, ma questa volta sostituiamo X all'uno anziché Z. E ciò che otteniamo solo da questi tre generatori dello stabilizzatore
è un codice che include i 16 stati mostrati qui, che otteniamo applicando gate Hadamard agli stati della base standard
corrispondenti alle stringhe nel codice di Hamming [7,4,3]. Naturalmente il nostro spazio del codice include anche
combinazioni lineari di questi stati. Naturalmente, i generatori dello stabilizzatore di questa forma sono chiamati generatori X dello stabilizzatore:
nessun Y o Z è consentito questa volta. Ora possiamo definire i codici CSS in
termini semplici: i codici CSS sono codici stabilizzatori che possono essere espressi usando solo generatori Z
dello stabilizzatore e generatori X dello stabilizzatore. Quindi nessun Y è consentito, e nessun X e Z nello stesso generatore dello
stabilizzatore. E solo per essere sicuri che questo sia chiaro, dobbiamo tenere presente che c'è libertà nel modo in cui scegliamo i generatori dello stabilizzatore per i codici stabilizzatori,
e ciò che questa definizione sta dicendo è che un codice CSS è uno per il quale è possibile scegliere solo generatori Z e X
dello stabilizzatore, ma in generale potresti scegliere generatori dello stabilizzatore diversi che potrebbero non essere generatori Z o X dello stabilizzatore, se lo desideri.
Ecco il più semplice esempio non banale di codice CSS che possiamo avere, dove ci sono sia un generatore Z dello stabilizzatore
che un generatore X dello stabilizzatore, e verificarlo non richiede altro che uno sguardo, dato che sappiamo già dalla
lezione precedente che questo è un codice stabilizzatore valido. Lo spazio del codice è unidimensionale: è lo spazio generato da un
ebit più, e possiamo osservare che i nostri due generatori dello stabilizzatore agiscono banalmente su questo vettore considerando
le due espressioni di un ebit mostrate sullo schermo insieme all'interpretazione dei generatori dello stabilizzatore come controlli di parità nelle basi 0,1
e più-meno. Il codice di Steane a 7 qubit è un altro esempio di codice CSS, perché per questa
scelta di generatori abbiamo solo generatori Z e X dello stabilizzatore, e sappiamo già che questo è un
codice stabilizzatore valido. Il codice di Shor a 9 qubit è un altro esempio: questa volta abbiamo sei generatori Z
dello stabilizzatore e solo due generatori X dello stabilizzatore, e va bene: non è necessario che ci sia un equilibrio o una
simmetria tra i due tipi. È però fondamentale che abbiamo effettivamente un codice stabilizzatore valido, il che significa
che ciascuno dei generatori Z dello stabilizzatore deve commutare con ciascuno dei generatori X dello stabilizzatore. Quindi non puoi
semplicemente scegliere i due tipi di generatori in modo indipendente, e dirò qualcosa in più su questo più avanti nella lezione. Ora discuteremo il rilevamento
e la correzione degli errori per i codici CSS, e ciò che scopriremo è che la proprietà che abbiamo osservato per il codice di Shor a 9 qubit,
ovvero che possiamo rilevare e correggere errori X e Z in modo indipendente, vale in generale per i codici CSS.
Per spiegarlo ulteriormente, consideriamo un codice CSS come il codice di Steane a 7 qubit, ma potrebbe essere un codice CSS diverso se
WEBVTT
preferisci. L'idea di base è che i generatori Z dello stabilizzatore rilevano gli errori X,
ma sono completamente ciechi agli errori Z, perché i generatori Z dello stabilizzatore commutano sempre con gli errori Z.
Inoltre, i generatori Z dello stabilizzatore commutano anche con qualsiasi gate Z che potremmo scegliere di applicare come
correzioni per gli errori Z. Allo stesso modo, i generatori X dello stabilizzatore rilevano gli errori Z, ma sono completamente
ciechi agli errori X e alle correzioni. Quindi possiamo in sostanza pensare ai generatori Z dello stabilizzatore come che rappresentano un
codice lineare classico che protegge contro i flip di bit, ovvero gli errori X, mentre i generatori X dello stabilizzatore
rappresentano un codice lineare classico nella base più-meno che protegge in modo completamente indipendente contro i flip
tra gli stati più e meno, ovvero gli errori di flip di fase o errori Z. Quindi ora è abbastanza chiaro cosa sta
succedendo con il codice di Steane: è semplicemente un codice di Hamming [7,4,3] per gli errori di flip di bit e un codice di Hamming [7,4,3] per gli errori di flip di fase.
Ancora una volta, il fatto che i generatori Z dello stabilizzatore e i generatori X dello stabilizzatore commutino è necessario:
non sarebbe un codice stabilizzatore valido se non lo facessero. E si potrebbe dire che è una fortuna che il codice di Hamming [7,4,3]
funzioni così, ma ci sono molte altre scelte che possono essere fatte per coppie di codici lineari classici che ci daranno un codice stabilizzatore valido
quando combinati in questo modo. Tornando ora ai codici CSS in generale, supponiamo che i generatori Z dello stabilizzatore
consentano la correzione di fino a, diciamo, j errori X e i generatori X dello stabilizzatore consentano la correzione di
fino a k errori Z. Nel caso del codice di Steane, j e k sono entrambi uno perché
il codice di Hamming [7,4,3] può correggere un flip di bit. Ma in generale questi numeri j e k possono essere diversi.
Ne consegue, per la discretizzazione degli errori, che il codice CSS può correggere qualsiasi errore su un numero di qubit fino al
minimo di j e k. Questo perché quando misuriamo la sindrome, un errore arbitrario su un certo
numero di qubit collassa probabilisticamente in una qualche combinazione di errori X, errori Z o entrambi, e poi
gli errori X e Z possono essere rilevati e corretti in modo indipendente. Quindi, purché abbiamo due
codici lineari classici che vanno d'accordo, nel senso che ci danno generatori X e Z dello stabilizzatore che commutano, il
codice CSS che otteniamo combinandoli eredita essenzialmente le proprietà di correzione degli errori dei due codici nel senso che ho appena
descritto. Nota che c'è un prezzo da pagare, però: non possiamo codificare tanti qubit quanti potremmo codificare bit
con i due codici classici, perché il numero totale di generatori dello stabilizzatore per il codice CSS è la somma del
numero di controlli di parità per i due codici classici, e ogni generatore dello stabilizzatore dimezza la dimensione dello spazio del
codice. Ad esempio, il codice di Hamming [7,4,3] consente la codifica di quattro bit classici perché abbiamo solo
tre controlli di parità per questo codice, mentre il codice di Steane a 7 qubit codifica solo un qubit perché ha sei
generatori dello stabilizzatore. L'ultima cosa che spiegherò sui codici CSS in generale in questa lezione riguarda gli spazi dei codici CSS
e come appaiono, e questo ci darà anche l'opportunità di esaminare in modo un po' più dettagliato la relazione che deve intercorrere tra
due codici lineari classici affinché siano compatibili, nel senso che possiamo combinarli per formare un codice
CSS. Considera un codice CSS arbitrario su n qubit e siano Z1 fino a Zs le stringhe di parità di n bit
corrispondenti ai generatori Z dello stabilizzatore. Questo significa che il codice lineare
classico descritto dai generatori Z dello stabilizzatore, che chiameremo CZ solo per aiutarci a ricordare che questo
è il codice corrispondente ai generatori Z dello stabilizzatore, prende la forma mostrata qui sullo schermo. In parole, il codice contiene ogni
stringa u il cui prodotto scalare binario con ciascuna delle stringhe di controllo di parità è zero. Se volessimo, potremmo anche
considerare un codice diverso derivato da queste stesse stringhe, che chiameremo DZ. L'idea qui è che pensiamo a
queste stringhe Z1 fino a Zs non come stringhe di controllo di parità, ma piuttosto come generatori.
A questo punto non è chiaro perché vorremmo pensare a questo codice, ma possiamo farlo e risulterà rilevante per questa
discussione. Questo codice si chiama codice duale di CZ ed è comunemente denotato CZ perp, dove perp indica il simbolo perpendicolare
come apice, ma lo chiameremo DZ, e sarà abbastanza facile da ricordare perché D è l'abbreviazione di
duale. Possiamo fare qualcosa di simile anche con i generatori X dello stabilizzatore: questa volta CX è il codice lineare classico
le cui stringhe di controllo di parità corrispondono ai generatori X dello stabilizzatore, e DX è il codice duale di questo codice. Come nota a margine,
possiamo ora descrivere le condizioni che devono valere affinché CZ e CX siano compatibili nel senso che possiamo
accoppiarli come codice CSS. In termini di questi codici stessi, nello specifico deve essere che
DZ è contenuto in CX, o equivalentemente che DX è contenuto in CZ. Ora è
possibile descrivere lo spazio del codice CSS derivato da questi due codici. Un modo per descriverlo è che
è lo spazio generato da tutti i vettori che hanno la forma mostrata sullo schermo. In parole, sembrano sovrapposizioni uniformi
sulle stringhe nel codice duale DX del codice corrispondente ai generatori X dello stabilizzatore, spostate
o XOR-ate con stringhe nel codice CZ corrispondente ai generatori Z dello stabilizzatore. Vedremo come appare questo
nel caso specifico del codice di Steane tra poco. Ha senso perché gli stati nello spazio del codice devono essere
autovettori con autovalore +1 di tutti i generatori dello stabilizzatore, e in particolare la moltiplicazione per uno qualsiasi dei generatori X
dello stabilizzatore è equivalente all'XOR con la corrispondente stringa X. Ecco perché queste sovrapposizioni uniformi
su DX spostate da stringhe diverse appaiono così. Scelte diverse per lo spostamento
rappresentato dalla stringa y in questa espressione possono dare lo stesso vettore, quindi questi stati non sono tutti distinti, ma collettivamente generano
l'intero spazio del codice. C'è una simmetria qui tra i generatori X e Z dello stabilizzatore e
i codici a cui corrispondono, quindi possiamo usare quella simmetria per descrivere vettori nello spazio del codice in modo analogo scambiando X e Z, ma
dobbiamo anche scambiare la base standard con la base più-meno, ed è per questo che le operazioni Hadamard compaiono in questa
espressione. Ora, per l'esempio promesso, cioè il codice di Steane, finiamo con queste due possibili
codifiche degli stati della base standard zero e uno. In particolare, possiamo codificare lo stato zero come una sovrapposizione uniforme
sulle otto stringhe nel codice duale del codice di Hamming [7,4,3], che risulta essere la metà delle stringhe nel codice di Hamming [7,4,3], e
possiamo codificare lo stato uno in modo simile, tranne per il fatto che tutte le stringhe vengono sottoposte a XOR con la stringa tutta-uno in questo caso.
WEBVTT
perché quella stringa si trova nel codice di Hamming [7,4,3] ma non nel suo duale. Un ultimo commento qui è che spesso
non ci preoccupiamo molto di come appaiono i vettori negli spazi dei codici, perché in generale non è necessario saperlo per usare i
codici. Quindi, se questa spiegazione non era chiara, non è davvero qualcosa di cui preoccuparsi troppo, ma è certamente
naturale chiedersi come appaiono i vettori negli spazi dei codici CSS, e questa descrizione fornisce una risposta a quella
domanda. Ora discuteremo un codice CSS specifico noto come codice Toro, che è un esempio di qualcosa noto come
codice correttore di errori quantistici topologico. Questo codice è stato scoperto da Alexei Kitaev nel
1997. In effetti, il codice Toro non è un singolo codice, ma piuttosto è una famiglia di codici, uno per ogni numero intero positivo
almeno due. Questi codici possiedono alcune proprietà chiave. La prima proprietà chiave è
che tutti i generatori dello stabilizzatore hanno peso basso come operazioni di Pauli. In particolare, avranno tutti peso
quattro, e questo è positivo perché significa che ogni misurazione dei generatori dello stabilizzatore non ha bisogno di
coinvolgere troppi qubit. A volte si parla di codici Quantum LDPC o codici quantistici a bassa densità di controllo di parità
(Quantum Low Density Parity Check), e questo è ciò che si intende con questo termine, dove in questo caso "bassa" significa quattro. Quindi il codice Toro è un esempio di
codice Quantum LDPC. Il codice Toro ha anche quella che si chiama località geometrica, il che significa che non
solo i generatori dello stabilizzatore hanno peso basso, ma è anche possibile disporre i qubit spazialmente in modo tale che
ogni misurazione dei generatori dello stabilizzatore coinvolga solo qubit che sono vicini tra loro, il che rende queste misurazioni più facili da implementare
in linea di principio. E infine, questi codici hanno una grande distanza, quindi possono tollerare un tasso di
errori relativamente alto. Ecco come funzionano questi codici. Prima di tutto, sia L un numero intero positivo
di almeno due e considera un reticolo L per L con cosiddetti confini periodici. Ad esempio, ecco un reticolo L per L
per L uguale a 8, e nota che le linee a destra e in basso sono linee tratteggiate. L'idea qui è che vogliamo pensare alla linea tratteggiata a destra come alla stessa linea di
quella a sinistra, e allo stesso modo la linea tratteggiata in basso è la stessa linea di quella in
alto. Quindi, se volessimo realizzare fisicamente questo tipo di configurazione, avremmo bisogno di tre
dimensioni. In particolare, potremmo formare un cilindro abbinando prima i lati sinistro e destro, e poi piegare il
cilindro in modo che i cerchi alle estremità, che erano i bordi superiore e inferiore del reticolo, si incontrino. Oppure
potresti abbinare prima il bordo superiore e inferiore e poi i lati: funziona in entrambi i modi e non importa quale modo scegli per gli scopi di questa
discussione. Ciò che otteniamo è un Toro, ovvero una ciambella, anche se pensarlo come la camera d'aria di un pneumatico è
forse un'immagine migliore da avere in mente, perché non è una ciambella soffice: il reticolo è diventato la superficie di un
Toro. Ed è da qui che viene il nome "codice Toro". Il modo in cui puoi muoverti su un
Toro come questo, supponendo di poter muoverti tra punti adiacenti sul reticolo, sarà probabilmente familiare alle persone che hanno giocato a videogiochi della vecchia scuola,
dove se ti sposti fuori dal bordo superiore dello schermo, emergi in basso, e lo stesso vale per i bordi sinistro e destro dello
schermo. Per la maggior parte, questo è il modo in cui descriverò questo reticolo, piuttosto che parlare specificamente di un
Toro in uno spazio tridimensionale. Poi immaginiamo che i qubit siano
posizionati sugli spigoli del reticolo, come illustrato qui sullo schermo, dove i qubit sono indicati da cerchi blu solidi.
Nota che i qubit posizionati sulle linee tratteggiate non sono solidi, perché abbiamo già rappresentato quei qubit
con quelli lungo il bordo superiore o il lato sinistro, tenendo presente che le linee in alto e a sinistra sono esattamente le stesse linee di quelle
indicate dalle linee tratteggiate in basso e a destra. Quindi, se contiamo tutti questi qubit, otteniamo 2 × L² qubit, e un
modo per vederlo è osservare che otteniamo L² qubit sugli spigoli orizzontali e L² qubit sugli spigoli verticali.
Questo è quindi il layout dei nostri qubit. Per descrivere il codice Toro stesso abbiamo solo bisogno di descrivere i generatori dello
stabilizzatore, e ce ne sono di due tipi. Primo, abbiamo i generatori Z dello stabilizzatore,
e questi corrispondono alle piastrelle o alle facce nella figura. Secondo, abbiamo i generatori X dello stabilizzatore,
e questi corrispondono ai vertici nella figura. Quindi, ad esempio, ecco un
generatore dello stabilizzatore: stiamo producendo un prodotto tensoriale di un'operazione di Pauli Z per ciascuno dei qubit che toccano questa piastrella, insieme alle matrici identità
su tutti gli altri qubit. Questo ci dà un'operazione di Pauli di peso quattro. Ed ecco un esempio di generatore X dello
stabilizzatore, dove abbiamo matrici di Pauli X che agiscono sui quattro qubit incidenti a questo vertice, insieme alle
matrici identità su tutti gli altri qubit. Quindi, ancora una volta, è un'operazione di Pauli di peso quattro. È importante che per entrambi
questi tipi di generatori dello stabilizzatore includiamo quelli che si avvolgono ai confini periodici. Ed ecco un esempio di generatore X dello stabilizzatore
che fa questo. Ora, per ottenere un codice stabilizzatore valido, abbiamo bisogno che i generatori dello stabilizzatore
commutino. I generatori Z dello stabilizzatore commutano tutti tra loro perché Z commuta con se stesso e l'identità
commuta con tutto. Lo stesso vale per i generatori X dello stabilizzatore. È anche chiaro che un generatore Z dello stabilizzatore e un generatore X dello stabilizzatore
commutano quando agiscono in modo non banale su insiemi disgiunti di qubit, come per i due generatori mostrati
qui. La possibilità rimanente è che un generatore Z dello stabilizzatore e un generatore X dello stabilizzatore si sovrappongano, e
ogni volta che ciò accade si sovrappongono sempre su due qubit, quindi i generatori dello stabilizzatore commutano perché
ZZ e XX commutano. Ora, questo non è un insieme minimale di generatori dello stabilizzatore. In particolare, se moltiplichiamo
insieme tutti i generatori Z dello stabilizzatore, otteniamo l'identità, perché ogni qubit viene moltiplicato per Z due volte,
una volta per ciascuna delle piastrelle che tocca il qubit. Ciò significa che moltiplicare tutti i generatori Z dello stabilizzatore insieme
tranne uno ci dà quell'ultimo, quindi non sono indipendenti, ma se ne rimuoviamo uno qualsiasi otterremo
un insieme indipendente. Lo stesso vale per i generatori X dello stabilizzatore. Quindi possiamo rimuoverne uno di ciascun tipo,
e non importa quali rimuoviamo. Questo lascia L² meno uno generatori dello stabilizzatore di ciascun tipo. Per essere
chiari su questo, e questo è qualcosa cui ho accennato nella lezione precedente, teniamo effettivamente conto di tutti questi generatori dello stabilizzatore, e in senso strettamente
operativo non scegliamo effettivamente uno di ciascun tipo da ignorare, ma ai fini dell'analisi del codice possiamo
immaginare che un generatore dello stabilizzatore di ciascun tipo sia stato rimosso, in modo da ottenere un insieme di generatori minimale, tenendo
presente che potremmo sempre dedurre i risultati di questi generatori rimossi, pensandoli come osservabili, dai risultati di tutti gli altri generatori dello
WEBVTT
stabilizzatore dello stesso tipo. Quindi il numero di qubit codificati da questo codice è uguale al numero totale di
qubit, che è 2 × L², meno il numero totale di generatori dello stabilizzatore in un insieme di generatori minimale, che è 2 × L² −
2 + 2, il che significa 2 × L² − (2 × L² − 2) = 2. Non ho argomentato, tra l'altro, che lo spazio del codice è non banale, ma in effetti
lo è, e ti lascio convincerti che non c'è modo di moltiplicare insieme generatori dello stabilizzatore in modo da ottenere
meno 1 per l'identità. Quindi questo è il codice Toro in sé, e a questo punto potrebbe non essere
affatto chiaro perché questo codice dovrebbe essere buono per la correzione degli errori quantistici. Resta da analizzarlo, e ciò che scopriremo è che è un
codice correttore di errori quantistici davvero straordinario. Per capire come il codice Toro funziona come codice correttore di errori
quantistici, inizieremo considerando diversi errori e le sindromi che generano. La prima cosa da notare è che
il codice Toro è un codice CSS perché tutti i nostri generatori dello stabilizzatore sono generatori Z o X dello stabilizzatore,
e ciò significa che gli errori X e Z possono essere rilevati e possibilmente corretti
separatamente. In effetti, c'è una semplice simmetria tra i generatori Z e X dello stabilizzatore che ci consente di analizzare gli errori X
e Z essenzialmente allo stesso modo. Quindi mi concentrerò sugli errori X, che sono eventualmente rilevati dai generatori Z
dello stabilizzatore, e puoi tradurre tutto agli errori Z, che sono eventualmente rilevati dai generatori X dello stabilizzatore, usando esattamente le
stesse idee. Ecco una figura che illustra i nostri 2L² qubit sugli spigoli di un reticolo L
per L con confini periodici, e possiamo immaginare che questo sia disposto sulla superficie di un
Toro. In questo momento tutti i qubit sono blu, indicando che sono qubit che non sono stati influenzati da
errori. Quindi dovresti immaginare che a questo punto lo stato di questi qubit si trovi nello spazio del codice per questo
codice. Come ho detto, la nostra attenzione sarà sugli errori X, e tra un momento useremo cerchi magenta per indicare i qubit che
sono stati influenzati da errori X. Gli errori X sono rilevati dai generatori Z dello stabilizzatore, che corrispondono
alle piastrelle nella figura. Quindi quello che possiamo fare è usare piastrelle bianche per indicare risultati di misurazione +1, ovvero
voci nella sindrome corrispondenti a quel generatore, mentre le piastrelle grigie indicano risultati di misurazione −1.
Puoi pensare a un risultato +1, cioè una piastrella bianca, come indicante che il corrispondente generatore dello stabilizzatore è felice: tutto sembra
a posto per questo generatore. Un risultato −1, cioè una piastrella grigia, invece
indica che il corrispondente generatore dello stabilizzatore è infelice, perché ovviamente deve essere successo un errore a causare questo
risultato. Quindi in questo momento tutti i nostri generatori dello stabilizzatore sono felici perché non si sono verificati errori. Ora, se pensiamo
a un generatore Z dello stabilizzatore, quello che sta facendo è misurare la parità dei 4 qubit che toccano la piastrella rispetto
alla base standard. Quindi un risultato +1 non indica che non si sono verificati errori X su questi quattro
qubit, ma piuttosto indica che si è verificato un numero pari di errori X, mentre un risultato −1 indica
che si è verificato un numero dispari di errori X. Ora introduciamo un errore X e vediamo cosa
succede. I due generatori Z dello stabilizzatore corrispondenti alle piastrelle che toccano questo qubit sono ora infelici, perché questo
errore X anti-commuta con entrambi questi generatori, o equivalentemente in termini della base standard ci troviamo ora in
uno stato in cui entrambi questi insiemi di quattro qubit corrispondenti alle due piastrelle hanno parità dispari. Quindi questo è l'effetto di un singolo
errore X. Quindi, se dovessimo misurare questa sindrome e sapessimo o assumessimo che si fosse verificato solo un errore X, saremmo
facilmente in grado di dedurre quale qubit aveva subito il flip e potremmo semplicemente riportarlo con un gate X. Ora vediamo cosa succede
quando introduciamo errori X aggiuntivi, e in particolare vediamo cosa succede quando si verifica un secondo errore X su un altro
qubit che tocca una delle piastrelle grigie, diciamo la piastrella grigia in alto,
così. Quella piastrella è ora felice perché si sono verificati due errori X sui qubit che toccano questa piastrella, e due è pari.
Quindi questi due errori X insieme commutano con il generatore dello stabilizzatore per questa piastrella. Un altro modo per dirlo è che
questo secondo errore X ha spostato tutti gli stati della base standard di questi quattro qubit dalla parità dispari di nuovo alla parità pari.
La piastrella a sinistra di questo nuovo errore X, d'altra parte, è ora infelice.
Possiamo continuare questo processo di aggiungere nuovi errori X, e finché formiamo una catena di errori X adiacenti, dove adiacente significa che i qubit toccano la
stessa piastrella, sposteremo effettivamente questo risultato di misurazione −1 in giro. E ciò che troviamo è che abbiamo sempre
risultati di misurazione della sindrome −1 agli endpoint delle catene di errori adiacenti. Quindi possiamo sempre rilevare catene di
errori X adiacenti purché abbiano endpoint. Potrebbero, tra l'altro, esserci più catene, ma torneremo
su questa possibilità più tardi. È tuttavia possibile avere una catena di errori X adiacenti che
non ha endpoint, il che significa che la nostra catena di errori potrebbe formare un loop chiuso. Quindi aggiungiamo altri errori
in modo che formino un loop chiuso così, ad esempio. Ora abbiamo un numero pari di errori X
su ogni piastrella, quindi ogni generatore dello stabilizzatore è ora felice. E ciò che abbiamo scoperto è che i loop
chiusi di errori X adiacenti non vengono rilevati da questo codice, perché otteniamo la sindrome tutta +1 in tal
caso. Questo potrebbe sembrare un po' deludente. In effetti, bastano solo quattro errori X adiacenti per formare un loop chiuso,
e speriamo in qualcosa di meglio di un codice a distanza 4. Tuttavia, alcuni loop chiusi di
errori X adiacenti sono essi stessi nello stabilizzatore. Ricorda che abbiamo un generatore X dello stabilizzatore per ogni vertice nel
reticolo, e se moltiplichiamo insieme generatori X adiacenti dello stabilizzatore, possiamo formare loop chiusi di operazioni X,
come abbiamo proprio qui per il loop chiuso che abbiamo costruito poco fa. Quindi alcuni loop chiusi di errori X,
come quello mostrato qui, non sono in realtà errori, perché sono nello stabilizzatore, quindi non fanno assolutamente nulla allo spazio del codice. Ci sono tuttavia
alcuni loop chiusi di errori X che non si trovano nello stabilizzatore e quindi rappresentano errori non banali che passano
inosservati al codice. E c'è un modo abbastanza semplice per caratterizzare i diversi tipi di
loop. I loop che attraversano ogni linea nel reticolo, cioè ogni linea verticale da cima a fondo e ogni linea orizzontale
da sinistra a destra, un numero pari di volte, sono sempre prodotti di generatori X dello stabilizzatore. Ciò include l'esempio
mostrato sullo schermo, così come loop che potrebbero essere molto più complicati, inclusa la possibilità che attraversino i confini periodici, ma
nonostante ciò, moltiplicando questi loop chiusi di errori X per generatori X dello stabilizzatore, possono essere effettivamente ridotti
WEBVTT
a niente. Ed è certamente vero, tra l'altro, che possiamo ottenere loop come questi solo moltiplicando insieme generatori X dello stabilizzatore, perché ogni generatore X dello stabilizzatore
inserisce un numero pari di operazioni X su ogni linea orizzontale e su ogni linea verticale.
L'altro tipo di loop chiuso che possiamo avere è uno che attraversa almeno una linea un numero dispari di volte, come
quello mostrato qui, che attraversa ogni linea orizzontale esattamente una volta. Ed ecco un altro esempio che attraversa
ogni linea verticale esattamente una volta. Quindi questi sono esempi di errori non banali che passano inosservati al codice, ma la cosa
fondamentale è che l'unico modo per formare un loop chiuso come questo è girare intorno al Toro, sia intorno al buco al
centro del Toro, sia attraverso il buco, o potrebbe essere entrambe le cose. Questa è una proprietà topologica
riguardante il Toro: riguarda fondamentalmente i buchi, ed è per questo che questo si chiama codice di correzione degli errori quantistici topologico.
In termini di questa visualizzazione di un reticolo bidimensionale con confini periodici, una catena in questa categoria deve
avvolgersi attorno a uno o entrambi i confini periodici in modo tale che sia impossibile contrarre quel loop a un
punto moltiplicandolo per generatori X dello stabilizzatore. Una tale catena potrebbe essere più
complicata di quella illustrata qui, ma questa è la più corta che tale loop possa possibilmente essere, perché deve in qualche modo avvolgersi attorno
a uno o entrambi i confini periodici. E ciò che questo implica è che il peso minimo di un errore non banale
non rilevabile è L. Qualsiasi loop chiuso con meno errori di quello deve rientrare nella prima categoria ed è quindi
nello stabilizzatore. E le catene di errori che non formano loop chiusi sono rilevate dal codice. E questo è tutto: ecco perché questo codice
funziona. E ciò che otteniamo è un codice stabilizzatore [[2L², 2, L]]: stiamo usando 2L² qubit per codificare 2 qubit, e il codice ha distanza L. Ora dirò
brevemente qualcosa sulla correzione degli errori con il codice Toro, anche se non andrò troppo in
dettaglio. Se misuriamo la sindrome e vediamo qualcosa di diverso dalla sindrome tutta +1, dove qui mi riferisco solo
ai generatori Z dello stabilizzatore, allora i risultati −1 ci indicano gli endpoint di una o più catene di errori X adiacenti, e possiamo tentare di correggere
questi errori abbinando insieme i risultati −1 e formando una catena di correzioni X tra di essi. E
mentre facciamo questo, ha senso scegliere i percorsi più brevi per le nostre correzioni. Ad esempio, se misuriamo una
sindrome come quella mostrata qui, potremmo scegliere questo percorso tra le piastrelle infelici e applicare gate X
come correzioni lungo questo percorso. Naturalmente, la catena effettiva di errori che causava la sindrome potrebbe essere stata
diversa, come quella mostrata qui, ma va bene: purché gli errori e le correzioni insieme
rientrino nello stabilizzatore. Potrebbe anche darsi che le nostre correzioni completino un loop attorno al
Toro, il che è negativo perché così facendo abbiamo causato un errore logico. Quindi questa strategia di correggere
lungo i percorsi più brevi corregge gli errori di peso basso, ma potrebbe non funzionare per errori di peso maggiore. Ma ovviamente non possiamo
aspettarci niente di più da qualsiasi codice di correzione degli errori quantistici. Forse più probabile, a seconda del modello di rumore, è che
osserviamo un certo numero di meno uno nella sindrome, e in questo caso possiamo usare efficienti algoritmi classici per aiutarci
ad abbinarli e trovare un errore di peso minimo che rappresenti la sindrome. Come ho menzionato nella lezione
precedente, questo potrebbe non sempre correggere la spiegazione più probabile per la sindrome, ma funziona abbastanza bene in generale
e ha sempre successo nel correggere errori con peso strettamente inferiore alla metà della distanza L. E dovrei anche
menzionare che esistono altre strategie più adatte a diversi modelli di errore. Sono passati oltre 25 anni dalla scoperta del codice
Toro, e in quel tempo c'è stato molto lavoro sui codici correttori di errori quantistici, inclusi
altri codici correttori di errori quantistici topologici ispirati al codice Toro, così come codici basati su idee diverse.
Certamente non posso fornirti un elenco completo di tutte le diverse costruzioni di codici conosciute, ma
gratterò un po' la superficie e menzionerò brevemente un paio di esempi ben noti. Primo: come risulta, non è
davvero essenziale che il codice Toro abbia confini periodici. Cioè, è possibile ritagliare solo una porzione del codice Toro e
disporla su una superficie bidimensionale piatta piuttosto che su un Toro. E ciò che otteniamo facendo questo si chiama codice
surface. Ad esempio, se tagliamo i bordi di un reticolo nel pattern mostrato qui, con cosiddetti bordi grezzi in alto
e in basso e bordi lisci ai lati, e di conseguenza includiamo i casi limite per i generatori dello stabilizzatore,
otteniamo un codice che questa volta può codificare solo un qubit, ma il codice eredita comunque le caratteristiche più
importanti del codice Toro. In particolare, gli errori non banali non rilevabili per questo codice devono
corrispondere a catene di errori che si estendono dal bordo sinistro a quello destro o da cima a fondo,
a seconda che siano catene di errori X o Z rispettivamente. È anche possibile tagliare
i bordi diagonalmente per ottenere quelli che a volte sono chiamati codici surface ruotati, e farlo può essere utile per rendere
i codici più economici in termini di qubit utilizzati. Ad esempio, se prendiamo questo codice surface
e scartiamo alcuni dei qubit, lasciando un quadrato orientato in diagonale, otteniamo un altro codice
surface, purché specifichiamo i generatori dello stabilizzatore al bordo nel modo corretto. Diagrammi come questo sono
utili per chiarire come i generatori dello stabilizzatore sono definiti, dove le piastrelle nere, incluse quelle arrotondate ai bordi, indicano generatori X dello stabilizzatore
e quelle bianche indicano generatori Z dello stabilizzatore. Quelle al bordo, tra l'altro, sono solo generatori stabilizzatori XX
o ZZ a 2 qubit questa volta. E vedrai comunemente questi diagrammi ruotati di
45°. Un'altra classe interessante di codici, che rientrano anche nella categoria generale dei codici topologici, sono i codici
colore. Non spiegherò esattamente come funzionano, ma un modo per pensarci è che sono generalizzazioni geometriche
del codice di Steane a 7 qubit. Quindi consideriamo il codice di Steane a 7 qubit e supponiamo che numeramo i nostri
qubit usando la convenzione di ordinamento qiskit, come mostrato qui sullo schermo. Possiamo quindi associare questi sette
qubit ai vertici del grafo mostrato qui. E ciò che troviamo è che i generatori dello stabilizzatore corrispondono
alle piastrelle o alle facce formate dai bordi del grafo, e per ogni piastrella abbiamo sempre un generatore Z dello stabilizzatore
e un generatore X dello stabilizzatore che agiscono in modo non banale precisamente su quei qubit che si trovano ai vertici di quella
piastrella.
Questo è bello perché, proprio come per il codice Toro, abbiamo la località geometrica per questo codice, quindi non abbiamo bisogno
WEBVTT
di spostare i qubit su lunghe distanze per misurare i generatori dello stabilizzatore. E il fatto che i generatori Z e X dello stabilizzatore agiscano sempre in modo non banale sugli
stessi insiemi di qubit è utile anche per ragioni connesse al calcolo quantistico tollerante ai guasti, di cui
parlerò nella prossima lezione. I codici colore sono codici correttori di errori quantistici che generalizzano questo
schema di base, dove facciamo essenzialmente la stessa cosa ma con grafi diversi. Ad esempio, ecco un grafo con
19 vertici che funziona. Questo ci dà un codice che codifica 1 qubit in 19, e risulta avere
distanza cinque. Questi si chiamano codici colore, tra l'altro, perché una delle condizioni richieste sul grafo è che le facce possano essere colorate con tre colori, cioè
possiamo colorare le facce con tre colori senza che due facce dello stesso colore condividano un bordo. I
colori in realtà non importano per il codice stesso: abbiamo semplicemente generatori x e z dello stabilizzatore per ogni faccia indipendentemente dal suo colore, ma i colori
risultano essere importanti per analizzare come funziona. Quindi queste sono due famiglie di codici molto note,
ma ci sono molte altre costruzioni conosciute, incluse quelle basate su idee simili a queste famiglie di codici nonché
su quelle completamente diverse. Un esempio specifico di codice correttore di errori quantistici scoperto di recente
da alcuni miei colleghi di IBM è noto come gross code, così chiamato perché una "grossa" è una dozzina di
dozzine, ovvero 144. In particolare, questo codice codifica 12 qubit in 144 qubit e ha
distanza 12. Non spiegherò come funziona questo codice in dettaglio: è simile al codice Toro, tranne per il fatto che ciascuno dei
generatori dello stabilizzatore coinvolge due qubit aggiuntivi che sono un po' più lontani. Non ha un embedding planare
come un codice surface, ma ha quello che si chiama un biplanar embedding, nel senso che sono necessari due strati di qubit anziché
uno. Rientra in una famiglia di codici chiamati codici bivariate bicycle, e ciò che è particolarmente notevole è
che sono molto più efficienti del codice Toro o di un codice surface, nel senso che molti più qubit possono essere codificati mentre allo stesso tempo
tollerano approssimativamente lo stesso tasso di errori. Per il gross code, sono necessari altri 144 qubit per la misurazione della
sindrome, quindi il numero totale di qubit richiesti è 288, il che lo rende un candidato molto promettente per la tecnologia
di oggi. E questo conclude questa lezione, che ha riguardato le costruzioni di codici di correzione degli errori quantistici, inclusi i codici CSS, il codice Toro e uno
sguardo ad altre costruzioni di codici quantistici, inclusi i codici surface e i codici colore. Spero che ti unirai a me per la
prossima e ultima lezione della serie sul calcolo quantistico tollerante ai guasti, che affronta la sfida di eseguire
calcoli su stati quantistici codificati usando operazioni e componenti di calcolo che sono essi stessi soggetti a
errori. Arrivederci alla prossima.